thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys today we have Mr Steve
Toronto
flipping Legend Living Legends I'm glad
uh Steve is here I wanted to talk about
this awesome topic
um what do you think about how uh
you know how how like some ancient
martial arts that have been around for
like hundreds of years or whatever
they're starting to get debunked by like
Fighters that challenge these Masters
and to prove that they're useless [__] a
Tai Chi Master yeah and there's a lot of
like uh talk on the other side of like
hey you're like disrespecting what was
like an art form or like a cultural
symbol for such a long time not all of
it's about
someone up yeah uh how do you feel about
that happening as a martial arts Grand
Master as a Japanese guy
yeah well I I feel like
traditional martial arts yeah it's not
practical
like like MMA is like
like all the best things just like Bruce
Lee's talks about that same thing
happened in like tricking you know it's
it's like uh it went from sport martial
arts and then we started doing like more
flips and twists and all that and then
all the ogs were like you're not doing
all this other things
yeah using less kicks and saying it's
like not practical is like
um I think there has to be like an
awareness of like yeah we're not these
things aren't practical but it is has
roots in like martial arts
um you know what I realized so I did a
deep dive on martial arts okay and what
we think is traditional is actually not
traditional oh so so some of it doesn't
go back that far for example karate
is actually newer than boxing Western
boxing Jack Dempsey in Japan like a big
time boxing star in America was getting
super popular and at the time the
Japanese government was like [__] like
we need a striking thing
and then they went to Okinawa and they
found something and then they're like oh
we could do something with this because
karate used to be called Chinese hands
not cool name they made that up Karate
just means empty-handed but that they
made that word up it's it was a national
Japanese propaganda thing to bring a
striking art into Japan damn because
Okinawa is like it's like half Chinese
half Japanese it's like its own little
like Kingdom it's a different Kingdom
from Japan and they were influenced by
um kung fu yeah but there was no name
like Kung Fu is like
not one thing either it's just like a a
bunch of martial art groups right and
then I just went down the line of like
okay karate
came in like Japan from Okinawa and then
the founder of Judo who took Jiu Jitsu
and Judo and um the actual practical
fighting styles that the uh Samurai used
and they said well we don't need these
things because it's just fatal we don't
need this for the sport so they turned
it into a sport
so like
Judo that you see today is not the
action that's why you see such a
difference in like Jiu Jitsu and Judo
when it used to be the same exact thing
that was a that's a Japanese martial art
that Samurai's used because they're like
once you lose your sword then how are
you gonna kill this other guy you can't
punch him in the face so you Gotta Throw
Them slam them how are you gonna kill
somebody that has armor and then later
on it was like you can't kill someone at
in college with a competitive
so they removed all the Fatal [__] stuff
whatever and even today like the Judo
today is different from the Judo in
1920. so then like that's why people
talk about like old school [__] used to
be way hardcore because they'll be like
oh you don't finish with like arm bars
and [__] like that in Judo now because
it's like oh that's two that's two that
that's too fatal but then Jiu Jitsu kept
it so it's like all this like it just
keeps changing to fit the time and the
sport that's why so then they talk about
karate and how traditional it is and
whatever right but what I found out is
like they took out so many practical
things to systemize something
a hundred people can learn so that it's
sustainable for everyone so then what
we're looking at is an incomplete
martial art original Karate was was more
like MMA they had throws they had locks
they had strikes they had everything
because it was like what do you use as a
Warrior when you when you don't have
your sword so it's like you gotta just
do what you can to kill somebody with
your hand so that that was the actual
like I guess progression there was no
like you have to do it this way whatever
whatever it became like that because
nationalism and Sport and then you I dug
deeper with China and I'm like yeah how
come Kung Fu sucks if it all came from
the same thing like how come you do this
hey we got your China guys here huh
the China guys are upset I did that for
like five years ago I kicked in the
mouth I was bleeding everywhere but you
were using Crane style you gotta you're
fighting man yeah I do yeah you gotta
know which animals and I had a blindfold
and I was trying to sense
it all actually came from like
um like Shaolin Kung Fu or like there
was another technique
it you know Ip Man his he learned from a
female
yeah and then it'll
so there was like um
it was called Flying Crainer basically
if you trace the origins right they all
they all have forms so the way that they
taught karate back in the day is like
they would have
like moves of different like blocks and
kicks and stuff right and then so if you
trace the origins there is like a set
that everyone did but then like it like
for example The Shaolin Monks they were
Warrior monks that were fighting off
people that came in it was actually used
in war but over time when you have 400
years of peace and they're not using it
to kill people then they remove all the
Fatal things that was practical because
maybe it doesn't look cool for theater
like wushu that was like from formative
it just evolved to like yeah this is for
performance
and then now people that weren't
Warriors for like 300 years are like
saying that this is warrior [__] they
don't even test it and then they get
killed by actual Warriors and that's
what I saw as like oh [__] so these
moves
used to be practical and over time
they say this is the traditional way but
it's actually evolving yeah in a way it
is kind of dumb when like uh like MMA
guys go
I can beat this guy up like it is sort
of like a stupid thing to say right
because it's like guys are just mean
dude I think those are because it's like
you're beating up a [__] old Chinese
guy
what is the time it's the other way
around though I don't I think it's not
the MMA guys I think it's the guy in the
silk pajamas yeah I could [__] up [__]
you up yeah and it's the MMA guy going
on oh [__] all right but also though
it's just like okay
I'm not gonna [__] beat the [__] out
of you because it's like what's the
point I guess it's for YouTube yeah it's
a spectacle it's a thing but in my head
I'm just like
to me when I see that stuff I always
feel some type of way because it's like
it feels like they're punching down you
know which is the MMA guy best feeling
punch
[Laughter]
velocity of domination better than the
dragonfly
loser [__] it's a big one bro when I see
when I see that I'm like yeah I just
feel some type of way I don't really
like it you don't like it huh I don't
like see because it's dude do you see
it's always a guy in a ponytail that
wants to fight guy it grows like he's
like yeah and he looks like he's not in
shape at all so it's like okay why are
you like why are you gonna even talk to
these guys who want to fight you don't
worry I've been a vegetarian for 15
years
there's this one guy who's like he's
like an Aikido black I forgot what
martial art he was but like he looks
like he owns like he just he has a
ponytail he's like these big tall white
guy owns a Miata yeah and a lizard and a
Miata and a lizard and an iguana and no
he uh he starts fighting with his MMA
guy and then my MMA guy just slaps him
in the ear and he goes oh oh [__] hold
on
it's funny but like it's funny but then
I watch that and I go like my heart
breaks a little bit because I'm like but
isn't that kind of cool to MMA but I
showed Mercy like he didn't even hit him
with a quote he's just like let me just
argue a taste I'd argue he blew his
eardrum
but when I whenever I watch those videos
I have yet to see an MMA guy go hard
yeah yeah it's more like a big brother
I've seen the ones the Nam fan one was
pretty hard The Man Fan one is like man
fan what are you doing dude why are you
spending time do you think that how
about this you need to be doing it
you're a legend you know you think that
these guys deserve to be beat up the
dudes that have mystical Powers yes
why because they're selling that vs too
and then it's basically like Colts
that's exactly why I'm against those
yeah you know it it it's just messed up
that they they're teaching all this and
taking people's money and bro if you
believe that and you spend money for
that you got bigger problems isn't there
a little bit do you feel slightly a
little bit of a conflict if those
martial arts even though they're pretty
phony are rooted in like Asian [__] not
because there's always some white dude
with a ponytail
and also
think it's an Asian thing I think
they're con artists yeah because I think
they're selling a drink they're I
actually think they're tainting real
Asian [__]
by Yeah by like they're like not I don't
want to say like appropriate what is it
like commercializing uh excluding
they're faking it right it's like
it's like there's Ninjutsu schools in
Japan and those aren't legit no really
bro because first of all no one was
supposed to know who the ninjas are what
what do they teach in Ninjutsu how to be
a ninja like it's okay like it's like
bro isn't there a song for this
[Laughter]
like okay so check this out when you
watch all of these like ninja schools
right
like the whole odd like the whole group
of people that are learning are white
weaves like they're like cosplay fat
white guys
and everybody in Japan like we have real
[__] like we have kickboxing we have
kyokshin we have
like they are laughing at these guys
because it's like um larpers yeah like
they're learning how to [__] do smoke
bombs and run away and like but you know
what they would say it's so stupid they
would say like in the streets there's no
rules so like boxing Jiu Jitsu
kickboxing all that stuff it's just like
non-existent in the streets where
anything goes because you can get hit
with a white weeb shuriken
but going back to what Joe said about
like uh the older martial arts that
existed like yeah even wrestling like
Reco Roman wrestling pancreation was
like like the ancient Greek version of
MMA that they were doing what did you
call it pancreation yeah they would put
like I think the wrestling with like
open hand Stripes yeah so they were
doing their own version of that
in like ancient Greek time and that's
what has lasted over time is the
wrestling the Western boxing grappling
is like because you have to use human
resistance it's not choreographed you
know actually um the book of firing so
so muslashi he's like this legendary
swordsman in Japan right and even during
those times because the thing is like I
think in the west they have this idea of
Japan being this like land of Samurai
but what they don't know is there's been
200 years ish of Peace where the samurai
became arrogant guys with swords with
the license to Kill so they're just a
bunch of bully like imagine like they're
cosplaying they're going around cutting
people up because big men on campus kind
of thing yeah but with no challenges so
what Musashi did was he's like I want to
be the best [__] swordsman and what
I'm gonna do is like Pokemon I'm gonna
go to these schools and I'm gonna
challenge these guys because I want to
see if their technique actually works
because he he's like how can your
Technique work if you guys are just
choreographing these moves wait are you
saying that the spear and then they go
like this is
[Laughter]
I love that though
yeah it's so good when they literally
have he would literally go out and test
them to the death because he goes you
guys call yourself [__] Warriors
let's fight to the death and let's see
who the best swords technique is it's
the MMA guy exactly
concept of MMA and and actually being
practical has always existed and this
whole whole like school with dogma and
being like we're traditional that's even
a story in ancient times where like
let's say any school that believes
they're the best Elite Fighters that
have choreographed moves for 50 plus
years and claim that they're traditional
they always get [__] up so that's
that's basically like the lessons of
like
um I think like when people think you're
a traditional ancient thing but they're
constantly getting tested by people who
actually do practicals what do you think
about uh Kendo
Kendall's a sport oh so it's not no
there's actual so there's different
kinds of like yado
um which is a drawing
way there's like there's different Arts
but I think it all came from real
like killing right and warfare and then
it evolved to just like an art
I think if it's a sport then it's
challenged and tested yeah and then
they'll continue continuously evolve and
be practical yeah versus like if you're
just doing forms with the sword like you
guy that's like a swords forms guy
versus a guy that does Canada are
probably chop him the [__] up yeah he's
probably gonna kill him he probably
won't be able to do all kinds of fancy
[__] yeah think about exactly fencing
too like if you actually get a sword
with a guy that offenses he'll just stab
you up in like three seconds I've forgot
what the there's like a Eastern European
Sport with fencing and grappling wow oh
yeah and I forgot what it's called but
like one of the students at the gym he's
like this 15 year old kid that like
trains this I was like what what the
[__] you training I forgot the name but
it's like it's pretty [__] cool but
it's like you you fight with swords and
then you grapple yeah I think anything
with like competition it evolves kids
it's not like Muay Thai it's like they
do like hundreds of fights and then it
they're 17. yeah yeah because even Muay
Thai has the traditional aspect
[Music]
part of it so that's what that's the
part that keeps evolving so if you even
if you do like the ancestor of Muay Thai
and you're just doing forms all day
which is what we see in ombok if if that
if they didn't have the boxing component
that would be impractical too yeah
how do you feel about uh movie stars
like action stars that are not actually
martial artists
well I think it's all right yeah yeah I
mean it's like it's like yeah because
they don't have to really like be good
at sucking dick to look like you suck
dick
[Laughter]
partner right
he's on the rise someone's there turns
your chair on because you know that guy
actually doesn't even do Marshall and
you know that guy that's talking like
that he also doesn't do martial arts
yeah
love action movies because they see it
as different they don't see it as like
oh it's my [__] they just go that's
[__] cool like in there because stunt
fighting is an art form in itself yeah I
think it's like really [__] amazing
it is just real fighting doesn't look
cool yeah and MMA guys also love WWE
this guy Denver he's got a world tour
premium account well I get it though
fighting is Not Practical it's like the
completion opposite but it's so cool
I mean real fighting is like two guys
rolling on the ground for like
30 minutes and then someone breaks them
up 30 minutes
dude I I'll re-watch I'll re-watch a UFC
every now and then but I'll re-watch
John Wick 10 more times will you are you
sure yeah dude I [__] re-watch that
[__] all the time dude
you know what I mean
he does this
how cool is that because you know you're
like this will never happen right real
fights are over in like a second like a
minute yeah just like John Wick did he
does that in his movies too oh yeah
yeah he does
it's pretty funny though like how people
it's just too much Dogma I think my
favorite is when we had Brandon Lee The
Boxer here and then we asked him like
which martial you think is the most
useless and then he goes karate
he went physically oh man
dude I love karate I think it's so cool
but then you said something that you
didn't get to finish even mentioning he
was he was like oh no I would show you
this full contact karate but then you
didn't get to like speak on it what's
that oh the sports ride there's there's
full content yeah coaching kickbox like
bro you seen a real kill Christian fight
yeah those [__] are gangster
yeah because their philosophy was
actually like you can't just be doing
forms all day unless you see combat so
for them they're like you need to have
physical resistance to test if your
moves are correct or not and then they
actually evolved karate by bringing by
studying other kickboxing Sports they
actually did the first street fighter in
Japan they were the precursor to like K1
and all that because they invited all
the stand-up striking
um arts and they had an event that
because they wanted to see like how Muay
Thai guys fly and whatever guys and then
they would be more like hey that's an
effective roundhouse let's adopt that so
The kyokshin Roundhouse is actually the
Muay Thai round house and then um I
thought that was a pretty Innovative
type way and then the founder of uh
kyokshin maso Yama he used to be a
Shotokan guy and Shotokan guys
where the original ones that systemized
karate from Okinawa into these different
categories but for him he goes the type
of competition that Shotokan does it's
Point fighting which is like you stop an
inch away from your opponent and then he
goes but that's not a real fight it
doesn't stop there and then you can
assume that you knock them out but how
do you know you actually knocked them
out and then so he created a system of
full contact karate
um bare knuckle fighting
you're not allowed to punch to the face
and then and then maybe you wear a cup
or whatever you can kick to the face
though yeah you can kick to the house of
dude which is dangerous but you can kick
the face interesting
they'll be this close and then a kick
will go up and just knock out there yeah
and it's insane it's pretty crazy but I
think the philosophy behind that was
like it's hard to land and if you do
you're you should have blocked it it's
pretty it's just gangster but they have
these fights where it's like you could
do a hundred man challenge where you
fight a hundred dudes back to back or
whatever
um that's crazy and it's it's difficult
like you like to get a black belt you
have to fight 10 guys back to back
is just to get into the Crips yeah it's
pretty it's pretty hardcore but yeah
there's there's things like that and a
lot of the fighters from kyokin end up
in the MMA like um John Saint Pierre or
uh George St Peter uh there's a big
karate guy named uh Stephen Thompson
he's his name is Wonder Boy and he comes
out in his walkout song is the Wonder
Boy song from uh Tenacious D which is
pretty cool but he's like you you see
him and he's like the cleanest cut white
dude from North Carolina but in
kickboxing Crystal Clear like like a
karate style yeah yeah like he's the
only guy that's like Sidekicks
in MMA The Narrative is you can't win
fights like that you can't win fights to
be in a karate fights huh he's koing
dudes doing the crazy [__] and then does
like the the 540 crazy flip afterwards
like he's the man bro but he and he
fights at a high level he flat first
it's like sport karate and like um Point
fighting yeah yeah but the dot adapted
that's cool guys like Raymond Daniels
too
he's sick he's like a tricker fighter
yeah dude he started out in doing like
self-def I mean like in competition he
would do self-defense like routines you
do like a punch front over the thing is
he's like six foot whatever right his
his uh I think his half brother he's
like my my like five like low fives so
it's like a foot difference and he would
beat the crap out of him you want to see
Karate or anything work in a real
context you type in Raymond Daniels his
whole highlight reel dude he'll do a
two-touch spinning back kick to a guy's
face and Chaos side back he'll do a 720
like right hook and Chaos which is like
insane it's out of a [__] movie but
he's the man all those guys and they're
of course they know Steve Trotta because
but you know what how sick would it be
if someday one of them magic power dudes
actually got it oh my God [__] dudes
up with spells you're doing she blast
and then the MMA guys upper half of his
body he's just gone
is Whispering [__] in his ear he's like
but what if they pulled some live golf
[__] where they paid fighters to play
along with this one
[Laughter]
Mark dude I could sell WWE you're like
bro you sure
or I'll try to punch the guy and I go oh
yeah they're doing that in like uh
wrestling pro wrestling he's like he's
like but then some like Arab dudes
entered the game and they're like no
we're gonna pay this to make it real
that'll be so good they're like just for
one year and then at the end they could
go I'll take a bow sorry you guys all
get your bet money back there was that
Shaolin monk like that dresses in the
full orange bald whatever and then and
then he's been
um he made his rounds and like he was
like yeah I'm gonna try to bring Kung Fu
back and whatever but he's just doing
kickboxing I thought of like K1 and [__]
yeah yeah it was a thing where people
punch him and he just like [__]
blocks with no hands like these guys
yeah yeah I think once he got knocked
out though I think eventually from that
yeah that's illegal dude
[Laughter]
thank you